los partidos más relevantes son podemos
Perú es renovación popular somos Perú y
el oficialista Perú libre estos comicios
según los últimos sondeos de opinión en
Lima se va a elegir entre el centro
derecha y la ultraderecha mientras que
los analistas políticos están señalando
que al interior del Perú van a ser los
movimientos locales quienes van a
derrotar a los partidos tradicionales y
bueno los comicios comenzaron ya y se
espera que a las 5 de la tarde se
cierren todos los centros de votación a
las 7 de la noche se van a tener los
primeros resultados a Boca de urna y ahí
recién conoceremos si es que los
peruanos continúan respaldando al
partido Perú libre del presidente Pedro
Castillo o le manifestaron su rechazo en
las ánforas